yeah we've been in contact with our
senators and members of congress
and we can report to you that they are
safe and they do plan to get back to
work tonight finishing what they started
there when this mob descended on the
capitol
i want to show you some video here i
just got off the phone with
congresswoman susie lee who says she was
actually in her office when
this was happening in the chamber her
colleagues here huddling
as capitol police have their guns drawn
now sources
tell us who were inside the complex that
they started
receiving text messages from police
telling them to stay away from the
windows
see cover here right now congresswoman
lee remains in a lockdown awaiting a
continuation of the work she started
at one o'clock her time and here's what
she said about watching the complex get
stormed today
it was very scary because not only were
you seeing
our capitol police being overwhelmed
on tv across the street but then knowing
that there were
other you know instances that were
requiring some attention and you know
not
knowing if someone could possibly have
breached
the building that i was in right now
that curfew
is in effect in dc video here right at
sundown police trying to get a handle on
those riders you see them
using strobe lights tear gas grenades
clearing those
arm protesters now like i said we have
it in contact with other representatives
in washington all day congresswoman dina
titus actually tweeting this as she was
in lockdown
lawless domestic terrorists encouraged
by the president of the united states
attempting to destroy our democracy they
will not
exceed her words there congressman
stephen horsford telling us quote
this violence in chaos around the
capitol is a direct result of the call
to arms by president trump
and his allies who organized and incited
today's events now president trump's
twitter
actually locked for 12 hours the company
making that decision
after a series of disputed tweets about
what happened at the capitol today
and what happened in the election we did
reach out to the nevada gop about what
happened today and we have not heard
back
i'm david charns 8 news now